[Music]
all right what's up y'all I am back with
another cooking video because my wife
she's been making a lot of baking videos
and she's motivated me to get back in
the kitchen with the camera I cook every
single day it's just I don't always
bring the camera with me today I am
inspired to make a classic in my mom's
kitchen I see it this often after school
every day because it was just something
that was easy for my mom to make and
it's soy sauce chicken it's nostalgic
for me and I'm gonna make a nostalgia
for TIFF and Isaac my little helper that
roles have been reversed yep it's my
turn to film
I'm apologizing in advance because this
footage is gonna be very shaky I don't
have a city don't apologize for that I
can be really shaky too what do you
think this is a very relatively
expensive dish if you were gonna make
this like say once a week you'd be going
through soy sauce bottle it's like left
and right if you need to buy soy sauce
like every week it's pretty expensive
wait a second aren't you butin allergic
and stuff did you get gluten-free soy
sauce tonight wait but you just said
we're gonna go through tons of bottles
is that gonna be enough yeah I mean if
you mean like this bottle could probably
make two of these dishes okay and it'd
be done that's cheap I could squeeze a
lot out there so Chinese you know I'm
making China - wait so isn't Chinese
food usually cheap though how is this an
expensive dish because it uses soy sauce
I guess on our soy sauce I mean
historically I guess soy sauce is like a
for the wealthy for the important people
ends in a soy sauce really I didn't know
that way maybe I'm making this up I
don't know oh my gosh I caught you but
it's fermented
so this like ongoing annoying thing that
Casey there's a lot of times he always
says things like their effect like he
knows it for a fact and I'm always like
poking holes and his explanations of
things cuz I'm like oh really was it
really like that or are you sure it
wasn't like this or could have possibly
absolutely alright anyways soy sauce
chicken we're gonna start with the fresh
ingredients real quick ginger how much
ginger do use like if this is like the
root the girth of the root as to ten
slices kind of making this up as I go
[Music]
I said ten yep okay and the slice is
just like that stack of chips those are
going speck of chips check this out
yeah check it out that's me trying to do
my dollies skills all right let me
spread it like that car do something and
then go doggy left to right you go
slower though the trick to this is the
whole arrest okay
[Music]
all right show these guys scallions
green onions whatever you want to call
it one two inches too much pieces one
two oh why so big because we're just
using them as aromatics and we're not
gonna really eat these things we just
want the flavor now to get all the
flavor out of this little guy you're
just smashing and there you go now it's
all the fibers are opened up it's
smashed all you can smell it now - I
smell good
I'm smiling did your no suppiy oh no oh
man I'm getting hungry now
wait oh we got our fresh aromatics here
with the ginger in the onions the loud
secret I know star nice we'll do three
of these guys smell good you know I've
taken over your role completely I'm
filming and I'm sticking my nose in the
ingredients oh that's the best part
about cooking since you can't taste it
yet because it's still raw smelling is
the best thing but mm-hmm
there's no it smells like [ __ ] it does I
was gonna say that skillet do you ever
try making design oh yeah
no but that's a good idea what is it now
kind of like bear ears right there oh
yeah I see it and there's no smiley face
for the bear or it could be a cat you're
lifting it from the he's not playing too
much
much no more playing let's get serious
all right I'm not throwing that ginger
first flavor
nothing in this dish you will actually
eat other than the chicken all right all
right we got our next ingredients
Chinese rice one rice line if you're
making Chinese food this is a really
important increasing your team get drunk
off of it yes again it's uh-oh
17% yeah smell it you want smell I gotta
get this base but it has a very specific
aroma once you cook the alcohol out like
a cup yeah
bubblin you got two types of soy sauce
you got dark soy sauce you got regular
soy sauce they call it like soy sauce
but I mean I don't know it's dark and
light white soy sauce is the soy sauce
that we have at like most Chinese
restaurants that you would use to flavor
your foods the soy sauce that you use
for your sushi this this actually has
dinner up yeah that's a density of X
syrup
this is fermented wait longer than the
light soy sauce so that's why it's dark
soy sauce and since it's fermented
longer it's thicker it's for coloring if
you were to cook with just regular soy
sauce you wouldn't get that brown soy
sauce chicken color you need the dark
soy sauce for it you can find one those
gluten-free a new company adding regular
soy sauce see how wasteful this is
that's a lot and you're doing dark soy
sauce
yo crazy
hey it's gone oh dang watch this this is
how fake dark soy sauces it's like looks
like blood blood
oh yeah has the viscosity of blood
coming away trying to make it with you a
cup and a quarter thanks that means
you're gonna have some eczema problems
tomorrow after this huh maybe hopefully
not I realized I have been reading up on
X and a lot more here's the reason why I
stopped making cooking videos so I've
been studying a lot about what causes
eczema and like dietary things because
that's what people are saying and I've
been doing some testing on myself and
realized I and very sensitive to certain
things
gluten included that's the biggest
reason why I stopped making videos I
can't you know a lot of stuff you can
make gluten-free recipes stuff that's
not fun it's like painting without the
colors of the rainbow it's like yeah not
you're so exaggerating dough is so true
the wheat product you can't make things
about one product and then eczema I mean
this is this is nomination
I guess practice normally anyways but
trans fats and saturated saturated fats
activated those cute oh yeah they're
also really bad for you they're founded
in a lot of red meat Manny you eat a ton
of red me right no I've been doing a lot
more fish we couldn't make more chicken
videos cooking video see like this was
chicken I like chicken all right one cup
of sugar what is that is that brown
sugar washed raw sugar
oh it's less processed so it's tough
here
I read random stuff online I'm like sure
yeah that's like brown sugar
looks like band sounds like alcohol the
witches brew I'm distracted by myself
again what does it say
Oh red cooking this is a form of red
cooking it's a Chinese Way of cooking
where you use dark soy sauce and regular
soy sauce to combine for flavor and
color to color and flavor different
kinds of meats and today is chicken want
cheese for the salt well compensate for
that hey why are you licking the spoon
do you do that every time you cook yeah
gross
what's wrong with that I mean nothing
with me but what about Isaac what's
wrong with that it's all in the family I
guess and saliva is sharing spit I feel
like that's like a thing of like modern
society what's so wrong by sharing spit
yeah I guess you're right add more blood
no at 4 cups of water
how many did I do
three I think I just needed liquids to
rise above certain levels that we can
submerge our chicken bring to a boil now
that it's boil then start on the show
chicken thigh a leg I'm good at there is
stains it immediately oh wow
mucho Caliente you know how to say it
right muy bien I just say it with my leg
you're still think Kylie and BAE what's
wrong it's Caliente I always get annoyed
with KC when he's saying Spanish words
and he knows how to say them right but
he says it the gringo way I'm like come
on you know how to say it I am a gringo
though when I go to Mexico I'm like oh
so this is what a white guy feels like
when you eat around his ethnic friends
what do you mean like you just feel fish
out of water I don't know that's how I
felt when I first started hanging out
with you yeah you know how it feels
yeah that was really awkward I'd never
ever felt that way before when I first
started dating you and then it would
just be like nothing but Asians cuz I I
thought that Gio was Asian - I didn't
know she was a Mexican so I would just
be really like whoa this is the first
time I've ever experienced this and I
never noticed that that was the first
time I experienced being with nothing
but non-latinos you know what I mean it
was just really weird now it's normal
normal that's good we're stuck together
for life mm-hmm so I'm doing something a
little more different so I like to eat
my chicken off the bone that's why I
have these two guys in here already
mm-hmm now as you know chicken on the
bone or anything with a bone on takes
longer to cook so I'm doing that I know
that are you
I have had these de Beaune now because
my wife and my son they don't like
getting messy with bone they just want
to eat with knife and fork like
gentlemen and ladies so I the caveman it
must cook this for 30 minutes the bone
30 minutes and then the gentleman and
lady would only have to cook this for
like 20 minutes
oh yes I'm in a difference with the bone
pretty much and I'm gonna shred this for
you too oh thanks you're so thoughtful
of course of course
okay she's always so thoughtful whenever
you make dinner for us cuz sometimes
you'll make something for himself and
something for me and Isaac completely
separate and I'm like how come you
didn't just make us all the thing you
were gonna eat if you didn't want to eat
what we're eating music no cuz I know
you guys like this my like oh you're so
thoughtful you're the best baby I like
eating like a caveman I don't want
people to feel have a bad relationship
with food because I think that's
terrible to have like to food so I at
least at home you should be able to eat
comfortably and be like oh you like the
food I eat this is home home is good
home is where food and family come
together so I just wanted that to happen
here no thanks you're so thoughtful it's
stuck to think that your dinner was a
chore you know that's true good ever
since you've been cooking pretty much
every night I started having a better
relationship with food just realize that
right now in this very instant I've been
eating a lot more often
I've actually been finishing my plates
and it's true I've been finishing
everything that I eat or like that I'm
served dirt and stuff I'm just like whoa
who is this new Tiffany now I know you
incepted my mind
I wasn't administration ten-minute oh
good definitely smells like roses and
soy sauce mm-hmm that's where the rice
wine kicks in is like this rosy kind of
flavor to it now and put the regular
chicken or the dip bone drinking it
mm-hmm it's like doing laundry Oh cuz
you always do laundry huh you would know
what that's like
choices character I know I'm kidding as
long as you get to cook I'm fine with
doing all that that's perfect for me cuz
I love cooking I hate laundry all right
so we got enough to a boil now we are
going to lower the heat and keep it
simmering for 20 minutes oh really
how come you have to simmer it after it
boils because if you boil it at a high
heat it just gets tough you know like
the meat gets all like whoa it's like a
lower eNOS like jacuzzi
hopeful I mean he cooks all nice how'd
you learn that science class not really
but it is really scientific though how
the muscles contract no but if you
didn't learn in in science class where
you learn it from failures in the
kitchen oh no where I really learned
about heat and controlling temperature
with the meats is barbecue hey Lois low
low to the point where it's gonna be
super stuff and tender it's been 20
minutes now
[Applause]
like that Filipino dish Robo yeah that
one it's basically the same thing
oh really the different spices I mean
this is like the og one I'm assuming
this ability as the adobo uses soy sauce
to the soy sauce happens to be a China
the og rendition of a soy sauce and huge
chicken dish basically swapped out the
rice one that we have in here for
vinegar you gotta go go I will actually
want to try this in a taco I want to see
what that tastes like
since we're in a multi-ethnic household
now we always have rice and we always
have tortillas yeah and anything I made
those Mexican based I like to mix that
with rice and see how it tastes like
which isn't that far off for Mexican
cuisine has a lot of rice Chinese food
like this I like the thrown in tortillas
we make tacos out of it and see what now
it tastes like always interesting what a
mega toddler right now yeah you sure
it's not all the way in the back well
nothing at your buddy sesame seed
that's me see mmm Parker yo soy sauce
oh you like it oh god I just like that -
it means wife mom good I like that
that's a good combo now we know soy
sauce chicken you can eat it Chinese
sweat style you're gonna eat it Mexican
style
I'll see you got the rice already made I
didn't see you do that I'm a ninja with
my rice and you see us and I make
veggies oh my gosh then why are you
bowling it what hey lemme you're
concentrating face with your tongue
[Applause]
there we go why not finish product I
can't see any rice just know that
there's rice down there people Oh
finished product
there we go get some of this into the
rice in the bottom
Bon Appetit this is just like Mama's
recipe maybe you try it tell me you like
it yeah it's pretty good sorry such a
late dinner we got caught up with the
whole cooking process you know every
time we cook with the camera I like
doubles the amount of time there's now
at the spend time talking to you guys
and like explaining everything that's a
chore I like talking to you guys ignore
him these are a nice touch yeah that's a
little crotch a little flavor I like my
caveman style oh I hope you guys liked
this recipe video soy sauce chicken one
of my all-time favorite Chinese recipes
if you do make it make sure it's tag me
in your photos and looking forward to
see what you guys come up with
[Music]